ladies and gentlemen please turn off
your cell phones and enjoy our
production of lunch with greatness my my
my what a beautiful day I swear the Sun
is so hot I nearly melted indeed dr.
King but I suspect we didn't meet here
to talk about the wealth indeed brother
Malcolm unless of course we articulate
that's the Sun in this country shines
brighter on some than it does on others
yes but when the Sun does shine on us it
is growing the seeds of revolution I see
your point brother Malcolm but do not
those same seeds need to be watered with
love
I suppose that is the subject of some
discussion dr. King and I am all for
discussion brother Malcolm unless of
course the words devolve into
proclamations of hate well is that not
why we are here today dr. King the to
discuss yes brother Malcolm and I am
confident that as we discuss we are
going to discuss it and discuss it until
I say that our people have never
resorted to violence before the white
man gave them no choice but to pay him
back in the only currency
[Applause]
brother Malcolm is that what you really
have to say at this point in our lunch
indeed dr. King because we didn't land
on Plymouth Rock Plymouth Rock landed on
us
[Applause]
okay well yes all right yeah I've heard
you say that before
I don't know why we're talking about
rocks when in fact it is the flesh and
the bone and the the dreams I have a
dream that someday our children will be
judged by the content of their character
not by the color of their skin
same for me same for me in fact I
believe that one day a black man will
become the president of the United
States of America hopefully pay you
[Applause]
yes that's a given right that's a given
I mean but in order to get there isn't
he going to need the help of a strong
beautiful black women
the sister
gotta respect assistants
[Applause]
you